but it's the realness and that's why you
don't like it because you don't like the
realness which is what it actually is
which is what I'm talking about who
cares you're not you're not seeing it
happen
[Music]
beautiful hair Matt my name is Neely I'm
from Oklahoma City I'm a huge fan of
y'all Chris would love if you did a show
in Oklahoma City sometime
um anyways my question is so my fiance
we actually just got engaged a couple
weeks ago but the other day I noticed
that my toothbrush was wet oh we've been
together for almost seven years whoa and
I noticed my toothbrush was wet and I
was like I didn't brush my teeth so I
went up to him and I was like did you
use my toothbrush because he didn't have
his and he was like yeah I yeah
that's disgusting right and he's like no
it's not
so I guess my question is like maybe
Chris would you do that with Kristen or
is that disgusting or is it normal
because we've been together so long
should I not be grossed out by that
I think it's gross but whatever let me
know what y'all think
it it's the bane of my existence right
now why because I and let me tell you
why all right I I like my [ __ ] you know
me right okay my shit's my [ __ ] okay if
you want to drink some of my drink it's
yours now okay let me just chill have my
[ __ ] there's very few things that you
get to just kind of experience in your
own body and brushing your teeth that's
one of them okay so I've noticed the
same thing my toothbrush I walk over I'm
like no this has been like two years now
I'm like Chris did you use my toothbrush
and she's like
oh yeah and I'm like oh okay well that's
disgusting so what where's your
toothbrush she's like I couldn't find it
and then I go look for two minutes and I
find it right so look a little bit
harder for your toothbrush also don't
lose a toothbrush also if you lost your
toothbrush walk around with a dirty
mouth that's your Penance here's the
other thing too I bought and I'm not
joking 20 toothbrushes I bought 20
toothbrushes this way oh Kristen these
gold ones are mine about them all the
same the gold ones are mine and you have
your blue one okay okay
dude fire a bunch of blue ones or no no
I got her she has a blue one and I got
her she's also there's also like a green
one and a red one and she wants to use
it and like dude she'll just like
willy-nilly take one of the gold ones
and bring it in the shower which is fine
because I'm like okay hers is in the
shower mine's out here and then I gotta
bring mine in the shower I bring mine in
the shower and then I put it down like
wait a minute which one's mine the Gold
ones are mine dude it's so gross to use
someone else's toothbrush and let me
tell you why not because of the brushing
the teeth because some people brush
their tongue
dude that's disgusting but you [ __ ]
you're Mack it all the time on it hang
on if you're macking if you're [ __ ]
got your Mac on and your Mac in Non-Stop
with your mouth on the other one macking
away what the [ __ ] is the difference
between that and sharing a toothbrush
just illness the staleness okay fresh
ass toothpaste on it
Mackin is about fresh kissing mix of
saliva yeah beautiful temperature yeah
you know my temperature in my mouth is
meeting your temperature of your mouth
okay this is love making okay okay using
a stale toothbrush that someone else
brushed their [ __ ] tongue on or got
the [ __ ]
lettuce out of their teeth come on with
that but it's the realness and that's
why you don't like it because you don't
like the realness which is what it
actually is which is what I'm talking
about but like who cares you're not
you're not seeing it happen like I don't
know that [ __ ] only grosses me out when
like I'm visualizing it or seeing it
everyone who cares walking through the
door that's okay
all right well it's a tree it's the
truth I like that you did that that's
fine
what's this we're opening the garage
somebody drove out with a bunch of
people
dude it's just disgusting you don't
think it's disgusting and here's the
other thing I really actually don't I
really just I don't yeah if I was gonna
pick somebody
to do this with it would be Kristen of
course exactly which is why it's not
gross it's still gross it's not gross
dude
it's not gross she should divorce you
[Laughter]
that you think it's gross it means you
don't love her if you loved her you
wouldn't [ __ ] care dude does she care
it's yours no cause she actually loves
you
[Music]
oh just you yeah uh no I just I don't I
don't think it's gross and if you think
it's gross I think that's weird that's
just my take on it dude I don't know
what to say it's like you're macking
away you Mack all the time on each
other's mouths like who [ __ ] cares
also how annoying is it to
me getting all the toothbrushes and then
her still using for my tooth that's
that's a bit like is she trying to I
mean it's a little bit yeah it's like
that's like gangster [ __ ] yeah that is
actually it's pretty baller to be like
yeah I'm gonna use the gold ones how
many gold toothbrushes around my
bathroom right now for real they're all
I mean I'll take a picture of it and
I'll send it in is there a way to put
like a label on it like a tape with a
letter on it frankly I don't think that
that would matter yeah but we do have a
label maker yeah you have a label maker
try it out dude okay I'll try it out and
same advice for uh this woman but it
sounds like he gets the idea now like I
would imagine that if you call your
partner out on it for doing it that they
don't like it that they would stop
obviously Christian's such a [ __ ]
hard ass baller doesn't want to do that
this woman's husband might actually
respect her wishes and stop so maybe you
don't even need advice
[Music]